hi everyone i'm said sedguin of ttic and
this is a joint work with francois
lagala of nagoya university
so at the time we started this project
the question that we had in mind was
try we were trying to make a connection
between quantum algorithms and fine
grain problems
so of course in fine grain complexity we
consider these very basic and
fundamental problems such as lcs edit
distance knapsack subsets on pattern
matching etc
the thing that all these problems have
in common is that they're really simple
the algorithms are very easy and
straightforward the question that we try
to answer
is whether these very simple algorithms
are optimal
or can be improved around time for them
sometimes we can prove lower bound
sometimes turns out a better algorithm
exists
in quantum complexity we try to take
advantage of quantum physics
and improve the algorithms in terms of
runtime
it seems to be possible to make quantum
computers in practice
right now google microsoft and many
other companies are making quantum
computers these quantum parameters are
not as strong
are not very strong they only have
hundreds of qubits
but they seem to be strong enough to to
claim quantum supremacy
what google claimed a few years ago was
that there is a quantum algorithm
running on one of its quantum computers
it can solve the problem
but the equivalent classic algorithm if
you if you run it on any super computer
it would take a long time
because of the advantage that quantum
algorithms have we expect that some of
these problems can be solved faster for
example there is a list of problems that
we can solve exponentially faster there
are many problems that we can solve
polynomially faster
and there are of course some problems
that we know we cannot do anything
better than the classic algorithms
the question that we asked in this work
is very exactly which of these fine
grain problems is that can we improve
the runtime for them or can we prove
there is no speed up for them
this is that interesting question
because there is a big difference
between these two areas in quantum
complexity we usually
go
go very low level to design algorithms
sometimes we draw circuits
in fine grained complexity we look at
everything at a very high level we look
at the existing algorithms as blackbox
and then they reduce other problems to
them to either
give new algorithms or to give lower
bounds
i can tell you a little bit about their
basics for example there are many
conjectures in uh fingering complexity
one of them is apsp which says
a graph of
size n
we cannot find the distance between
every pair of m
in truly sub cubic times
or there is s-e-t-h or strong
exponential time hypothesis it says that
sat cannot be solved in time two to the
n times one minus epsilon
or there is another conjecture max plus
convolution it says that if you're given
two sequences of size n
computing the combinatorial convolution
takes at least quadratic time
now what we do is we look at these
conjectures we use them as bases and
then based on them we proved lower
bounds for other problems for example
one of them which is very famous is the
work on edit distance if it solves edit
distance in truly subquadratic time
we can look at that algorithm as a black
box come up with a better algorithm for
seth
for for sat which is inconsistent with
sedh so if you believe in scth then it
means that there is no better algorithm
for added distance
of course in quantum the improved around
times there are some very famous
problems that we can solve faster on
ordered search is one of them
given a 0 1 sequence of size n we are
looking for one element with value 1.
of course classically we have to look at
everything so that requires linear time
grover's algorithm which is the quantum
algorithm solves it for us in time
routine
the second problem is element
distinctness
there are many variants for it the
variant that i work with in this strike
has two separate lists of size n we want
to know if there is one element which is
shared between them
again that problem requires omega often
time if you want to solve it classically
but turns out in
quant with the quantum algorithm we can
solve it in time n to the two thirds
and finally pattern matching is a very
famous problem given a text and a
pattern we want to know if the pattern
appears in the text as a sub sub
string assuming that the lengths of the
pattern and the takes um are bounded by
n
we can solve it in linear time and of
course we need to spend linear time to
solve it classically
but turns out with the quantum algorithm
we can we can do that in time root 10.
what we had in mind for the project is
the following
we wanted to merge these two areas we
wanted to use the techniques of
fine-grained complexity but instead of
looking at the existing classic
algorithms as blackbox
we replace that by the existing quantum
algorithms
so everything is going to be classic
but in the end the algorithms we obtain
are going to be quantum because the
algorithms we started with as black
spots those are quantum algorithms so
this way we can come up with better and
better quantum algorithms for for these
problems
the two problems that we consider are
lps and lcs
in lps we are given a sequence of size n
we want to find the largest substring
which is palindrome
and as string is palindrome if it reads
the same both forwards and backwards
meaning that the first character is
equal to the last character the second
character is equal to the second to last
character and so on
so given a string
find the substring which reads
the same both forward and backward
find the largest substring of that
string that has that property
that is lps
lcs first of all
it's for the longest common substring
problem there's also another problem
which is called longest common
subsequence
the between the difference between these
two problems is that in a subsequence we
allow for gaps between the characters in
substring everything has to be next to
each other
so here we are considering longest
common sub string and because of that in
the solution the characters have to be
next to each other
so what is the problem
given two strings of length n
we want to find
a substring
which is shared between them and of
course among such top screens we want to
find the largest one question is what's
the size of the largest substring that
has that property
the reason we consider these two
problems is that they're pretty much
equivalent in the classic setting
in other words
we can solve both of them in linear time
the algorithm for both of them use a
suffix three and it's basically the same
thing
except that
one line of the code is different from
between them so for both of them we read
the input we make a suffix tree we find
one of the nodes that gives us a
solution for lcs if we find another node
that gives us a solution for lps so
pretty much everything is the same for
both of them
our conceptual contribution is that the
situation changes in the quantum
setting
we first show that both of the problems
can be solved in sublinear time
for lps our algorithm runs in time root
n
for lcs it runs in time n to the five
six and i'm ignoring all the polylog
factors for now
we also give lower bounds the lower
bound for lps is root n
the lower bound for lcs is entered two
thirds
and
what the combination of these results
show is that there is a difference
between lcs and lps because lps we show
we can solve in time root n
but there is a unconditional lower bound
of n to a two-third for lcs
so the two problems are definitely not
equivalent in the quantum setting
all right
in the remainder of this talk i briefly
tell you the overall ideas of getting a
solution for lcs actually the social
foreign lps follows from the same ideas
um so i don't mention that explicitly
okay of course for all of the problems
like this the first step is to do a
binary session on the solution size
so instead of maximizing the size of the
common substring we assume there is an
extra parameter d given to us we just
want to know if there is a solution size
d
if there is such a solution the output
yes if there is no such solution the
output no turns out we just need to do a
bonus edge on d and and maximize t so
from here on we just want to know if
there's a solution size d
for that purpose we designed two
separate algorithms the former works
well when the value of these are small
the latter works well when the value of
these large so the complexity of the
first algorithm is n to the two third
times root d
and the complexity of the second one is
n over root d now if this is bounded by
n to the 1 6 we run the first algorithm
otherwise we run the second algorithm
you can do the mass in the worst case
the runtime is going to be bounded by n
to the 5 6.
i'll start with the simpler algorithm
which is for the
lower d
um
okay so generally the goal is to find a
pair i j
such that the substrings starting from
the position i of the first string and
starting from the position j of the
second string are equal
that means that a i is equal to bj ay
plus 1 is equal to bj plus 1 all the way
to a i plus a i plus d minus 1 is equal
to b j plus d minus one
you can break that into two subtests
the first stop task is to just verify
that for an ing so let's say i and j are
given we wanna know if
if the substring is starting at i and j
are equal
classically that requires time of d
because we have to go over all of the
indices one by one
with grover's algorithm we can improve
that to root d
just think of this as follows make this
sequence of size d if the ice element of
the sequence is equal to zero it means
that
the ice element of the substring is
equal or are equal and otherwise it
means that the ice elements are
different
now we want to know if there is one
element in this sequence which is equal
to one
grover's allows us to to to find that in
time root
root n in this case the size of the
sequence is d so the over runtime would
be root d
now
we can reduce the problem to
element distinctness
put every substring of size d of the
first string into a list
x
and then every substring of size d of
the second string into at least y
we want to know if there is one element
shared between x and y
that we can do in time and to a
two-third
but on top of that we have to pay a
price for comparing these elements the
comparison time is root d
so the overrun time when merging these
two algorithms would be equal to n to
the two third times root d
okay so that does it for the first
algorithm
the second algorithm is a little bit
more complicated so what i'm gonna tell
you is how we can get a one minus
epsilon approximation for the larger
values of d then i briefly tell you the
idea for turning that into an exact
algorithm
okay so the one minus epsilon
approximation is really straightforward
just
subsample a substring s
of links one minus epsilon d from one of
their strings
then run the pattern matching algorithm
and figure out whether this
substring appears in the second string
if
if it does appear output yes
if it doesn't appear output no
now let's look at this algorithm it
definitely loses an approximation factor
of one minus epsilon
because if it outputs yes we we just
know that there is a common substring of
size one minus epsilon d
the runtime is going to be root n
because we just run pattern matching and
take and that takes root and time
the success probability is pretty low
we know the lower bound on the number of
such solutions is epsilon d over n which
is omega of the over n
so
the only guarantee that we can say here
is that there is omega of the over and
probability that this algorithm works
to improve the success probability we
can bring in amplitude amplification
it it improves the success probability
to pretty close to one
but then it comes at a hit on the
runtime instead of runtime root 10 now
we are going to have runtime n over root
d
and still the approximation factor is
going to be 1 minus epsilon
okay
so that does it for the second algorithm
but we're still losing an approximation
factor 1 minus epsilon
to resolve that i just
mentioned the thought experiment
let's say the solution is unique
there is one substring of links d which
is shared between the two strings
and there is nothing else which is
common between them
so in that case if even if you find a
one minus epsilon approximation we just
need to extend it from both ends
and that pretty much leads us to the
exact solution
the issue is for the case that there are
multiple solutions some of them have
size d some of them have size more than
one minus epsilon d but a smaller than d
so sometimes we start from the wrong
place we extend it from both ends but we
don't get to the actual solution
what we prove in the paper is that that
only happens if the strings are periodic
meaning that they're repeating
themselves and then for the periodic
setting we prove that
there's an alternative algorithm that
does that solves the problem and runs in
time n over root t
okay
um so the combination of these ideas
gives us a solution that runs in time
into the five six
it sells lcs and it does it with high
probability
there is also a trivial lower bound that
directly follows from element
distinctness
we can think of lcs as a you know a
strict journal generalization of element
distinctness
if the solution to lcs is zero it means
that the two sequences have nothing in
common
if it's at least one it means that the
two sequences have something in common
so lcs definitely solves element
distinctness and therefore the lower
bound and element distinctness also
carries over to lcs which means that
lcs requires time and to the two-thirds
i just want to wrap up by just
mentioning a
subsequent work that actually improves
our algorithm for lcs
their algorithm is actually tight the
runtime is entered to third which
matches the lower bound that we give
so
as the the upper bound and the lower
bound for lcs are pretty much
close together up to body logarithmic
factor is tight
and we can solve it in time enter two
thirds and then for the lps problem also
everything is tight
finally one open question um i guess
the idea of this work was to answer um
you know it was to find out the quantum
complexity of fine grain problems
the very interesting question is about
the
quantum complex of added distance and
longest kind of subsequence
classically we know that they require
quadratic time because of a reduction to
seth
um to be more precise the reduction goes
through an intermediary problem which is
called orthogonal vector
we know that in the classic setting
orthogonal vector requires quadratic
time unless
cess fails
the interesting thing is that orthogonal
vector we can actually solve in linear
time for quantum
so the reduction wouldn't work for
quantum
yet we don't know any better algorithm
for either an edit distance or lcs
so there could be two things
either we could give a better lower
bound to another problem which cannot be
solved in linear time for quantum that
would be very interesting
or it could be the case that we can
actually improve the runtime for any of
these problems